I've got three destroyed there are each
of them gives you a slightly different
angle on why this is important so this
is um
it's moving from um the UK that's why
it's in pounds okay
what's happened she's had a holiday
she's got a third there and Alford's can
access the internet mostly wherever you
are in the world so while she's in
Turkey by the way this is actually a um
it's actually a somewhat old story this
is a whole lot worse now because she
deliberately went on Facebook to put up
some photos right but depending on the
phone that you've got set up right if
you've got like iCloud backup or Google
photos or something like that on your
phone it will just start uploading
photos without telling you because try
to give you a hand and back up this
video and lose them yeah and it's going
to incur data costs now this happened
this is a big deal right and this is not
an isolated story let me give you
another one question said yeah look at
this one okay now this is a story that's
primarily about people complaining about
the costs of their daughter okay
and particularly about people saying hey
I've got charge it's about but I wasn't
supposed to be trying to submit so the
example that thank you here is this
woman this is uh again Australian you've
got this several thousand dollar bill
and she she somehow went over three
hundred kilos now she disagreed with
this okay now clearly if this happened
to you you'd be like it really really
like I don't think this happened now
think about this for a second okay
they've got to the opera's button to
disagree with this okay and so you
should and I believe it was repealed
eventually
how do you think that's gonna happen do
you think you're just going to go up to
them and say hey I didn't do it think I
want some evidence right they're gonna
need an explanation from you to say no
this is what my usage actually says this
is how much you're supposed to be
charged and this is how much you
challenge me and that's wrong okay so
you want to be able to say okay this is
what I did is how much it should have
cost even if usually this just happens
in the background without you
worrying about I've got one more story
which is really shifting laughs have a
look at this one just go just have a
look at that on title okay yeah this is
just a stuff up basically okay this is
just a stuff up however that's a real
implications for what happened was that
awful you don't you know we talked about
scientific notation scientific notation
and how the important number is is the
significant figures right the ten to the
power of whatever okay
so someone somewhere had a bit of a
problem with their tenth of the power of
whatever because instead of charging you
225 volts which by the way close that
that's two instead of charging him that
much
they charged you this much now as you
can imagine right you can read this
article if you like he looked at his
phone he's like oh that's not what I
intended to do and he called Nell like
oh don't worry about it obviously you
don't have that amount of money in your
bank account so you can ignore this so
we did and then this happened this is
his um
this is his bank account so this is just
the I have this I have a CBI app on my
phone right and it shows you have any
available funds how much available funds
you have that as you can see he has
rather not very much right now what's
happened his account is overdrawn
because back when he just automatically
said yes and I'll put through his feet
which he thought was 225 it put in the
220 2.2 million or whatever that was
erroneous but now just pulled that out
of his bank account and as you said well
okay you don't have that it's cool
we'll just call you in debt to us 2.2
million dollars which is exactly what is
on his bank account says now what do you
think would be the effect the effect on
him of open
his phone and seeing this what's going
to what practically looking you're
putting it back down okay okay if your
funds rather if your bank account is
overdrawn obviously the bank I'm not
gonna let you keep on drawing money at
that because how do we let you draw this
in that in the first place so how do you
think he was able to like you why lunch
that day catching boss so when I go to
the shops right and I go and put
something I don't carry always no cash
anywhere cuz I don't really need to so
I'm gonna go to the F Plus machine I'm
gonna tap my card and it's gonna say
card declined I don't know how you ever
had this happen to you when you're like
here is your regular debit card right
that's not cool that's a little cool
having all of your access so just your
daily kind of things happen to you
because a bit of stuff they did but but
here's the thing though how long do you
think it took them to take it back took
him days for job enough days with no
access to money of any kind even though
it got fixed that's kind of a bit of a
big deal does this make sense